it's so delicious oh it's great so we
need a [ __ ] burger guys that's what
after this [ __ ] yes I do
get hotel room and then let's go like
this and drive fast like have you ever
did you ever just rock out yeah put on
um put on Ted Nugent's stranglehold so I
can show you how you rock out I'd like
to see that I'd like to see this yeah
yeah audio people my age Japan Tapia
people my age understand rock are you
[ __ ] idiots don't know yeah
yo dudes don't matter [ __ ] nope rock
yeah take your wig off double live gonzo
hey be take your wig off take your wig
off rock out with the wig off though hey
show me your bottom teeth yeah slap that
slap it yeah that was good though man
yeah hey your here's distracting hey
have more stuff here pocket yeah yeah
hell yeah
you're not old at all put more stuff in
your pockets like a janitor yeah [ __ ] it
yeah yeah dude yeah
there is maybe wrote while your jeans up
so we can see your psoriasis ROI your
jeans up yeah this is up went from
uncomfortably gay to uncomfortably white
yeah now that's the longest song in
history whatever yeah anyway very nice a
rock bro Ian's not in my pocket it's 20
bucks yeah oh yeah when is the man
dragon coming
huh you [ __ ] yeah dragon decides to fly
in and [ __ ]
the comedy landscape [ __ ] yo-yos yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]